fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby we got George Janko up in
this the man the myth the legend make
sure my phone's off kid Dynamite I call
him kid Dynamite I like that kid
Dynamite 30 years old taking things over
he's got a beard he's a Syrian everybody
he's a Syrian and no one in this room
knows what the [__] that means besides
me and George I barely know what it
means that's an old and I'm a part of it
yeah one of the oldest cultures one of
the oldest it was actually our uh our
New Years two days ago really April 1st
is our New Year's and that ain't no joke
why isn't it why isn't it January 1st
like there was the world
I don't know
do you know no you don't what's that
stupid what's that third New Years this
they just have their New Year's yeah I
know why January 1st is their New Year's
it's April no it's in April 1st I know
why April 1st is their New Year the
Syrian New Year now what a difference
our April 1st is uh a joke a joke yeah
April Fool's Day and that's your new
year it just doesn't it doesn't look
good for us yeah yeah well that's a show
I'll see you guys later
thanks for having me guys
you're a bit OCD
talk to me about that OCD yeah it's not
a bad thing usually a lot of successful
people are very detail-oriented yeah I
remember when they put me on medication
I did yeah oh yeah when I was in the
third grade Jesus yeah they put me on
like these pills which you were addicted
to lateral Adderall oh ADHD yeah it's
more Ritalin which is like it was
Ritalin actually released yeah yeah it
was Ritalin
um and so I was actually pretty [__]
up dude because I already I was in the
third grade I just got held back
because I just didn't want to pay
attention or do any of what they were
telling me to do so because at the time
I was performing too by the way so I was
like being pulled out of school to go do
shows and do stuff so like I was
performing at a young age you're like a
child actor no I was a dancer so I I did
like yeah I was doing drag shows for
kids no no I was the kid for adults oh
okay oh you guys should know Hollywood
is very into it
um
you did Dancing Yeah Yeah I'm still a
dancer yeah bro I got movies when you're
a dancer bro that [__] never really yeah
it's like riding a bike but I got a
little chubby over kovid yeah but like
the answer there's a dancer in there
yeah I just lift my shirt and then my
absence
but then they they fed me this medicine
I was just really scared of making my
mom and dad more sad and so I was
throwing up every day uh in the very
beginning of school so my mom would give
me the medicine I would go to school go
to the bathroom hide my throw up like I
would try to hide it so like throw up
because I thought I would be in trouble
for throwing up right so every day I was
like throwing up until one day I got
really pale and passed out you threw up
because of the medication yeah I was
like very allergic to it and and nobody
knew bro I went through some weird [__]
they they thought I I didn't know I was
dyslexic until high school so they I was
wearing glasses at one point because I
read the alphabets the wrong way but I
have like better than 20 20 Vision so I
was like wearing glasses getting dizzy
making it worse because I didn't need it
until one freaking beautiful actual
teacher that cared about her kids was
like hey come here and she like sat down
took my glasses off and she's like hey I
need you to I'm going to read you these
questions you answer it verbally and I
was uh already testing at a high school
level weird so I was really smart but
stupid at the same time it's like my my
uh cousin had my second cousin had a
really bad stutter and his dad used to
call him stupid and used to hit him like
God but this is damn this is dark
spirited they didn't know they didn't
know they didn't know his dad love to
somebody thought he could but you didn't
love him so he'd go like this hey he
didn't love them
my mother as a kid said this is not good
it's not working whack like the question
yep you fix the stutter it did okay I
probably made it yeah he's terrified
yeah another there was another cousin in
the family I'm not going to go into
details who
was the father suspected the child was
gay
and basically would would give him a
spanking give him the what for
periodically just because you got to get
the [__] out of them so you gotta beat
the [__] out of him this is we've come
a long way he's older no we've covered
I'm saying we've come along really old
so
George to us the story sound insane
right because
my day you guys get it I thought in your
day Jesus was telling people to love me
I think man he was but I the point is if
you had been my son I would have smacked
you in the head until you figured out
those letters
the reason he did that because you
thought you had it bad
I just yeah family members trying to
beat the gay out of their kid yeah
and they're removed though like second
cousin yeah that story may be made up
too but but you know it's happened
that's [__] I feel bad for this guy Not
only was he beat as a kid but you just
removed them out of your family he's
listening right now like what the can't
have somebody who has he was gay with a
stutter that's secondary
if you're not gonna respond to my
beatings then I don't know
back then though like they thought that
was just waiting kids that's what you
did
there's so much research now it's like
hitting does nothing for kids nothing no
it's not true I've never had it yeah and
that's such a lie it is so stupid I told
my dad hit you oh [__] yeah he did wait
hold on did you have a beard in third
grade though almost they actually nared
my mustache that's not a joke I'll
FaceTime my mom when you're in third
grade yeah because my mom said I was too
young to shave and I was tired of being
called a sand monkey which by the way
the last time I got called sand monkey
was by Theo Von bro he came on impulsive
rubbed my head he goes aren't you a cute
little sand monkey and I was just like
you know what but it felt good it was
from New Orleans you know why because
he's from New Orleans because I missed
days where you could just say [__] that
obviously you don't mean you're just
[__] I don't mean that yeah you know
a little bit I felt like he did mean it
the way he looked at me I was like oh
there's a bunch of racism yeah yeah you
can't have that accent and not be racist
yeah I think there's a little of a damn
the kids called you sand monkey growing
up oh yeah oh that was nothing bro uh
racism is Alive and Well everywhere oh
bro I was I was a kid when 9 11 happened
so you just removed my friends right
then like it's just they're all check
please yeah but the Syrian Arab Arabian
oh the same thing yeah I was called sand
N word yep that was called sand ninja
all the words that I was called growing
up I can't even recite them anymore yeah
they'll get us kicked off YouTube yeah
well actually you guys are pretty much
primarily white oh no we're getting
suppressed as we speak we're videoing
who was doing the calling was it was it
black kids was it everybody everybody
dude dude it was like we and Middle
Easterns ended racism yeah because
everybody's like no we'll just turn on
them like it was a it was a pretty
serious thing I heard it but you know
what I never really I never ever got um
offended to like the hate I don't know
why you have a good sense of humor maybe
didn't take it to heart I really just
didn't care what were they beating you
up colonial sand ninja though that's
different uh I did get beat up that's
why I did martial arts because I was
like okay I'm done with that
um I and then
what martial art did you do I did Muay
Thai and I did Brazilian Jiu Jitsu okay
damn that's how I know you're younger
than us because back then Taekwondo
Taekwondo gay right
you guys are Reckless why'd you do this
yay I can buy a black belt I never
jerked off in Taekwondo Quest once you
guys doing the locker room yeah I never
did that you're [__] kids up and I
did a a little bit not too much uh but I
did a little bit of um
yeah so one of my uncles uh was like a
bodyguard had to go through these type
of trainings and so like he would always
mess with me with these like moves and
stuff like like uh like pressure points
this one's like yeah without the wrist
and the spine like all these little
things and then uh the ones right here
are the worst yeah they actually helped
uh I hurt somebody's wrist because they
like put my girlfriend in uh in a like a
like a headlock at a party because he
was drunk and he was stacked bro this
dude was huge and I got so nervous I was
like dude this guy's so big so I did
that but I did it too much and I heard a
pop good and it just went like this and
then my girlfriend's like yo that was
you didn't have to do that but that was
also super hot bro I I went home I was
like what I did to that risk just wait
till I do that to you yeah
like Don't Mess with the Zohan and then
we just sat there she walked back and we
did nothing and we did nothing but talk
about it it's like 15. yeah
uh no this is actually two years ago oh
really yeah yeah was that it was at a
party here and it was with Belle my
girlfriend the ones that you the one
that's great [__] that could have been
bad let's cut that I don't want my side
host to get excited
I don't want my side hose so you you
came up exactly how because I met you
through Logan Paul yeah but you guys
were friends from childhood because he
grew up in Ohio you grew up in what
Arizona right I met Logan out here uh I
was doing like uh I was interning at a
recording studio and um
that to me was just like it didn't feel
like it was your calling it wasn't my
calling it just I I don't like being
beat down for something I don't love I'm
willing to take the beat down if there's
light if there's light at that that's
your passion yeah
um I I was in a recording studio and so
okay so I did music when I was in
Arizona in Arizona I thought I was the
[__] I was doing music videos my song
was on the radio damn I was like you
were singing Yeah we actually played one
of my fingers could you look up uh up in
this club up in this club by the way not
duh up in this disc Club
um yup right there up in this club it
should be right there the first time
what so I was I was like 16 when this
had a 2010. so yeah I was like I can't
wait to see this this is the greatest
already you know if this is copyright at
all or I have no idea okay so we might
have to try something
we could not be I don't know but I'll
try to give you the rights here I'm
giving them the rights yeah whatever I
win regardless I get the money here we
go
people are like at school just like
or whatever I was already creating
[Music]
all these kids in the background are
from my high school who's this young
fella that's me what yeah I was a kid
and I produced and wrote and everything
synthesized
[Music]
and you're 16. 16 yeah like 15 16. I
wrote the song when I was 14. you look
40 but still
that's another face
but this is this is
that's so [__] funny dude dude but
when you're in high school you drop your
own music videos I bet the kid you were
popular so so it went South quick it's
not about what's up I'll tell you what
happened what's up really quick so first
of all that music video for two like no
for a year I was telling people like yo
I'm shooting a music video and at first
they're like yo that's lit and then it
got canceled because my cousin's
shooting it from Chicago so we were
trying to make things work and it got to
the point where everybody's like yo
George is a liar he's like not telling
the truth he's a liar so I I was begging
people one day uh the music video uh the
day happened and only one kid showed up
just to prove that I wasn't [__] and
that I was [__] lying but when he
showed up
my cousin was shooting and my dad
financed it by renting gear so even if
you showed up and you weren't
professional it looked like a twenty
thousand dollars yeah so my the guy
walked in he goes oh what the [__] and
so he calls one dude up and he goes yo
you want to believe this George this is
before social media he goes George
janko's doing a music video next person
next person next person it I woke up and
my eyes started getting watery because I
was like only one [__] person's here
how the [__] am I gonna shoot this music
video and then my dad looked at me goes
just keep going just keep doing you just
keep pushing he goes it'll work out yeah
put that Blazer on keep dancing Habibi
we got here
one more
and then they put makeup on me I can't
cover the beard let's take a little
break with our friend George here
Atlanta I'm out in Atlanta next Thursday
Friday Saturday Atlanta Georgia come get
some April 13th through the 15th then La
Jolla Comedy Store La Jolla California
right outside San Diego's June 2nd
through the 4th and I'm jumping across
the pond to Europe Belfast is June 15th
Glasgow uh Manchester London Cardiff and
then Dublin's June 25th get your tickets
at thickboy.com
uh let's go helium Portland helium uh
I'm there April 20 22 and in Port
Charlotte Florida Comedy Zone the vasani
theater May 4 5 and 6. also live fight
campaign for UFC 287 this Saturday live
on thick boy YouTube with myself Brian
Callan Cheeto Vera and a very special
guest come watch UFC 287 with the boys
Cowboys fight campaign 7 P.M Pacific
live on thick boy YouTube but b as I
told you this Saturday it's
action-packed dude UFC 287 fight card is
a crazy rematch who you have dude long
time Rivals Alex Pierre and Izzy
adesanya will face off again for the
middleweight title throw down your shot
to win big with DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the UFC oh I got new customers can bet
just five dollars on a pre-fight money
line and get 150 in bonus bets if your
fighter wins plus all new customers I'm
sorry all customers can get
excitement with a DraftKings same game
parlay that should say same fight parlay
combine multiple UFC 287 bets into one
for a shot of even bigger payout B Izzy
Alex Pierre you got who you got I I I
just have to go to pierra I mean just
3-0 against him I know he's just bigger
he's just bigger he just hits too hard
he can sit down on his punches and just
Corner him and start blasting I think as
he gets it done I think he learned from
his lesson does he wrestle nope I just
think he does what he did in the first
fight but doesn't get clipped and wins
this fight yeah I'm thinking Izzy
Gilbert Burns a huge favor to her masve
at all uh uh Adrian Yanez versus Rob
font is a fight of the night Kevin
Holland and pontenebo uh Raul Rosa Jr
versus Christian Rodriguez can you give
him to mirror yep I'm taking Rosa Kevin
Holland uh Adrian Jana's by decision uh
Gilbert Burns he's a five to one
favorite for god sakes but I think
that's gonna be a good turnout for Jorge
Maslow and then oxpear Izzy I'm taking
Izzy via decision all right
if you want to make some bank and watch
you UFC 287 with us on the live fight
companion thick boy at 7 p.m Pacific
Saturday make some money with my friends
at DraftKings download the app right now
use code fighter new customers can bet
five dollars on a pre-fight money line
and get 150 in bonus bets if your
fighter wins this Saturday at draftking
Sportsbook with the code fighter minimum
age eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details DraftKings
dude uh and then so just a bunch it
started from a bunch of people hating on
me like oh no he's actually doing like
blah blah blah all those kids want to be
in a music video 400 500 kids from my
school what bro I got so bad that like
no so good actually that there's a scene
if you move forward in the in the uh
there's a pool scene there it looks like
there's a hundred 200 people there and
there were still 200 people back because
we couldn't fit them so we were rotating
them and uh it was so cool like we even
wanted to go take it to a different
location and people were just like
texting each other and they went uh and
then KISS FM uh like Ryan Seacrest or
whatever the [__] it was they were like
Hey we're having a singing competition
uh
whoever wins gets to perform at Justin
Bieber's concert like 5 000 people
entered what and I won what so I got to
perform at Justin Bieber's concert now
when I was a kid
I would do anything I could to be in in
an entertainment field so when we were
driving and we heard a commercial do you
want to be the next Hannah Montana yes
you want me to hit a month yes do you
want to meet Selena Gomez absolutely
yeah and my guess what my parents are
doing while driving turning it up we
gotta listen and so there was an agency
that would scam you you know I mean like
they would be like hey you paid 200
bucks we'll put you in acting classes
and [__] put you in auditions we did
this nothing came from it and it was
weird bro they would make me I'm not I
dude this is gonna sound like I'm lying
I swear to God they would they're like
okay
we have agents is when I was young I was
like 13 14. they're like we have agents
that want to look at you but they don't
want to intimidate you so they're going
to be looking at you guys from far away
uh but you guys are going to walk this I
swear to God I don't think at the time
now if I was there I'd have been like yo
this is [__] weird first of all we're
all kids what strangers
said no either though because they're
not in Hollywood my parents are like
listen to them they don't know what they
do
[Applause]
and so I was like okay so we just you
know we did my parents are just they
just believed you know so much people
and uh so
that I just forgot about that agency
years go by I do the the the show
they're the judges on it I don't even
remember them not the people the agency
so the agency uh gave me a hug when I
won because I gave the judges hugs I'm
like hey thank you bro somebody took a
picture and found out the agency the
agency pictures from back in the day me
working with them and they're like
George rigged it it wasn't real and I'm
like they made this rumor it was this
thing called thedirty.com
and it was like this page where it we'd
have social media but people are gossip
there and they said that George's
Persian father Persian father paid ten
thousand dollars to win a one thousand
dollar prize listen my dad didn't come
from this country with nothing and
become very successful to spend ten
thousand and make one like it doesn't
work that way right yeah and so
I went there and I was trying to tell
people like no I didn't [__] cheat
but the whole school they didn't want
anything to do Jesus they hated me they
had this game called spit on George and
by the way there's a lot of Mormons
there so I was kind of like weirded out
but we were getting bullied by Mormons
that's how you know you get bullied
we're gonna get bullied
if Mormons ain't you Brothers
it was Pinnacle High School yeah
Pinnacle high school then I went to
Horizon
um so there's this thing called Mr
pinnacle
and Mr Pinnacle is uh they they
basically are you Mr Pinnacles like a
talent show but then you bring your mom
and then you do like these dances and
you do all this fun stuff the talent
portion part came and the principal came
she goes hey man I don't think you
should perform there's people throwing
shoes at you there's people throwing
drinks at you there's like we're scared
that it's gonna cause more Mayhem and so
my mom and the principal already talked
and they're like this is his last days
like he's we're transferring him because
he got too bad so I go hey let me
perform one more time now one of the
lines that they were lying about was
that I was lip syncing that competition
so I got on stage this is all recorded
it got on stage and I go hey these are
for the ones that booed me and I
performed and people when they heard all
the kids that like believed the lies
when they heard that I was actually
performing they got up and started
clapping so like I had this like
standing ovation in my school when I
left undeniable bro so like that was
like one of my moments in life where I
was like if I could I know some [__]
it's a victory but if I could get
through that [__] I could get through
the [__] Yes Man Jesus Christ but that
is how you make these like when you're
terrified you don't know how it's gonna
work and you just stand up and tell the
truth and you're like hey I'm gonna sing
[__] you guys yeah that's the formula
for Success
you have any idea what it feels like to
perform at your school and watch your
dad like sink in his chair and your
mom's like sitting there crying like
this but also vibrant in the middle just
like you know this song is hot though
because they were so worried or anything
they thought you're gonna get crushed no
they knew I was they knew you're
talented I perform bro well I can shut
[__] down when I went to my new high
school my mom begged me she goes yo like
just keep your head down don't I was
mouthy bro like I did the Sarah and
Justin Bieber exactly oh by the way bro
like I was the type of dude that would
sit at the Justin Bieber theater like
where they were watching his documentary
and I would just cry
like I'm a Believer and he went like
this that's your dick apparently you're
16. before you reach puberty
no but dude I just knew I wanted to be a
a performer I went to a school called
Horizon High School
and these people always want like the
chorus Awards they were like the school
for course and their [__] was so legit
that you had to audition the year before
to be in the in the chorus class so I
went in and I was like this is so cool
these people must respect me because I'm
like I'm an engineer and I walked in and
it was like first period because I
wasn't a part of the class and I went I
was like maybe if I could just talk to
her and I could just get on my knees and
beg her and be like yo like I came from
a different school he watched my music
video like I swear like I'm a musician I
could be a part of the school I'll
[__] I'll clean the gum underneath
I'll do whatever right uh and she looked
at me and she goes I'm sorry like no and
then one of the kids was like yeah you
have to audition next year unless you
think you're better than us and you want
to replace one of us and I was like no I
just you know I could just stand next to
you guys there's like a thousand of you
guys like one is not gonna make a
difference and they're like nope this is
how it is so who do you think you're
better than and I went home and I told
my mom I was like mom [__] pissed my
mom's like hey don't do anything about
it just shut up sit down don't get in
trouble and I was like okay the teacher
literally like dude this is like
homecoming's coming the teacher the like
proud course teacher gets on she goes
guys we're doing talent shows and we're
gonna do it at lunch I know seniors
leave but if you want to gather and
watch my students and when she said my
students that that irked me because I
was like that could have been me and she
goes my students are gonna be forming
and some other students and I was like
wait some other students I could enter
so I asked can I enter
and I entered the [__] talent show
bro and I [__] smashed that [__] and
won it and there's a kid that's in this
entertainment uh field his name's Bryant
wood the first time I met him is when he
lifted me up on his shoulders because I
won this two competitions You've Won uh
Justin Bieber thing and then this thing
yes oh I I've done way more conversation
than that and I'm competitive bro like
I'll go in because I have no friends and
I have nothing to lose so like I'll go
in there being like all I got to do is
take this one no friends I go I go I win
that and then uh the teacher had to give
me the homecoming tickets
get that teacher right and I literally
didn't go to homecoming because I did
this so she went up kind of bitter
because she already knew that like she'd
turn me down and she went to go give me
the tickets her and the vice principal
and I said no no I just wanted to prove
that I could have replaced one of your
students and I [__] walked away
gangster [__] damn hard as [__] though
but I [__] myself because then I
couldn't go to home yeah yes yeah and it
was free tickets dude I should have just
take it you know what I think you have
gone for years to drive and all that
stuff it comes from a great place but
you have
um very likable energy I appreciate that
man I mean that's that's that's that's
kind of um
I don't know where it comes from but I
think it's you're very honest about your
expression you're just [__] honest
you just let it all hang out so did you
open for Bieber are you performing they
said it was an opening for Bieber but
they like worded it it was like I
performed at the concert but outside the
venue good questions
yeah but you got to perform
at the Justin Bieber concerts to outside
they worded it perfectly it was it was
opening up for his concert literally
opening up for the doors
bro and but you know I did meet him I
was gonna say you get to meet him so
this is this is [__] crazy I grabbed
my my check
and by the way I still have to check my
mom carries it in the guest room of the
house yeah uh and so I'm walking my
check out and uh to the to my dad's car
to put it in and a kid pulls up in a
Segway and it's it looks exactly like
Justin Bieber but in real life he looks
a tiny bit different so I look at him
and I go this is this the the [__]
show's about to start like 10 minutes
there's no way Justin Bieber would be in
the parking lot by himself on a Segway
with no security guards bro there's no
way so I look at him and I go oh [__]
you almost got me and I did this and I
walked away
and my mom looked at him and she starts
smiling she goes it is you isn't she and
then and then he like Smiles at her and
they're like talking for a bit and I'm
shoving the thing in the car I'm like
Mom let's go it's not him and he looks
at me and I'll never forget like you
just look me in my eyes from like from
here to where that computer was and
there was a moment I was like dude if
that was him that would be kind of weird
right and he looked at me turned away
rode away and uh the next day all over
press Justin Bieber escapes his security
guards and goes in the parking lot
causes Mayhem with fans that's awesome
bad for you awesome I could have hung
out with Justin Bieber some got a
special moment with him though she she
did and when I was in the recording
studio in La years later I was interning
I went to school I was interning and uh
Justin Bieber walks in and he's working
on a project and I got excited I'm like
oh I'm gonna walk up to this dude I'm
gonna go up to him and I'm gonna tell
him like Hey dude I performed that
concert I was in a parking lot I I
missed my chance to meet you but like
now and then before I got to tell
anything uh the studio guy goes hey hey
what the [__] are you doing and I go
what I'm gonna tell a random story about
how I performed outside your concert I
almost met him
hey hey bro
what's happening I want to ask you if
you remember my mom
then I go I go but no and he goes no but
no the only time you talk to Justin
Bieber is if he goes hey buy a raise of
hands who wants to wipe my ass he goes
That's you you're the guy that raised
his hands you don't even speak you just
raise your hand and I was like oh this
is [__] degrading yeah and so I got
off I got outside I called my dad and
I'm like yo [__] this [__] like I don't
want to [__] work anymore they're
treating me like [__] I don't get paid
I'm like [__] I'm gone my dad goes yeah
[__] that man he goes We performed that
Justin Bieber's concert and I go yes I
was [__] trying like that that's what
I'm saying mom knows something yeah oh
dude my dad's lit my dad got [__]
stoned out of his mind with Big Daddy
Kane bro because my that guy that smokes
weed no he was with them for so long in
a where they were chiefing he got high
as [__] I had to drive home damn my dad
my dad is the biggest fan he's playing
my music non-stop in his liquor store so
he pays my dreams from his his liquor
store and then he broadcasts it and
sells the CDs that he made me he makes
profit off of my music tight move right
this guy walks in smoking a j and he's
just [__]
just Chief and my dad goes hey you can't
smoke in here put that up the guy puts
it out super respectful and then he's
just [__] you know doing his thing
and my dad goes you like music and the
guy's like yeah you know I do music
myself and he goes oh what's your name
he goes he goes Big Daddy Kane I'm
performing here in the Arizona thing
we're doing this back in the day type of
thing you should come and my dad's like
you know my son does music he goes look
and he's like showing him my music and
he goes wait that's your son doing the
music video he goes yeah yeah that's him
in the Blazer yeah
he calls me and he goes George do you
know Big Daddy Kane is and I was like I
don't know who the [__] Big Daddy Kane
was and I was like no he goes dude
Google him and I was like okay so I
Googled him and I was like oh [__] back
in the day in Arizona bro like big daddy
like what the f he's a celebrity he's
known right
so me and my dad got our [__] best
gear on and they took us in the back and
they're giving us a special treatment
because my dad gave the alcohol hey you
know take it thanks for giving us the
tickets so there he's in the back
drinking he's getting like buzzed and
he's getting really [__] excited and
then he goes in the back and just it was
the first time I ever smelled weed in my
life it just hit me in the face and I
was like what the [__] and these dudes
bro you couldn't see your hand in front
of you that's how much smoke was doing
the Snoop Dogg concert oh no bro it was
like insane like till this day I've
never seen anything like or maybe
because when I was young at the time it
was a lot bigger than it is but like at
the moment I was just crazy and my dad
they go on to the stage and my dad he
goes smoking a cigar he goes call your
mother
we made it
he in his mind bro this is it yeah this
guy's gonna sign my son this is it and
my dad's just kicking his feet up
smoking a cigar nothing came out of this
by the way no we never even saw him
again no he left the stage and went
somewhere else we never saw him again
yeah but my dad I'll never forget it
it's you just the way he looked at peace
in his heart he's like my son made it
yeah son and Dad so how did you meet
Logan though did did I really just go
off on it I'm so sorry that's okay he's
like I won a dance competition yeah
I met Logan when I was out here and um
but you originally came out here for
music music yeah and then um and then
some of my friends like hey man stop
doing that stop doing the music like do
the acting you're like really good and
funny like you could get into character
and and so um uh I found out about Vine
through Logan and so while he was doing
this I would like write
skits for him or like other influencers
and all I would ask was like hey like
can I be in them and then through that
he like opened the door for me so like
Logan not only like taught me how to do
it but he also like opened the doors for
all the other things so like regardless
of wherever I mean Logan go I'll always
like my career God gave him me to like
like help each other give you your start
oh yeah yeah
um and so he's got a crazy work ethic
right my buddy Kevin oh he's a dog said
even when he was like 15 that kid was
like he was never anywhere he was in his
room editing and Kevin was 15. uh I
don't know how old he was but you know
nobody that sounds true Kevin was was in
his crew no no he's he's not Kevin
McNamara's you know Kevin yeah good
looking dude right tall yeah yeah uh
yeah yeah he was always playing like the
good-looking dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's that's so awesome I was playing
the stupid kid yeah that did this oh
hey can we use you he's your stupid face
he's he's gonna get you're a girl in
this skin yeah it fits right you just go
oh my Vines were six seconds right yeah
yeah six [__] bro it was weird the
first time I ever watched a Vine um I
got invite Logan goes hey me and Jake
are about to shoot this Liar Liar uh
Vine and I go oh okay so I go there
and
I literally can't I can't even
exaggerate it Logan's sitting there
looking at me with one leg up he goes
dude get this joke and he's just [__]
dumping gas on himself and I'm like oh
my God this is real gas I'm smelling it
I'm like yo bro what are you doing he
goes dude so
or like alcohol but something that's
flammable but you could smell it and you
just like [__] just dumping it on him
and I'm like yo what are you doing he
goes so this is a joke right where I lie
to my brother and he goes liar liar and
he throws a match on me and I go
hey man like you didn't catch him you're
gonna edit the flames in there like are
you actually gonna set yourself on fire
he goes watch it literally throws a
match and I was like whoa and he just
jumps in the pool and they're all
watching the video I'll never forget
they're like looking at the videos going
like this because he burnt his [__]
dick oh God and he's like oh yeah that's
a great shot let's do it again gangster
I was like yo these These are dogs I
call my mom I go yo I go I think I can
make a living off of making like six
second videos yep lighting my balls on
fire that kind of stuff and did you did
you that especially at that time did you
guys know how far all this was gonna go
no dude I have this uh until this day I
I still go by this I don't know what the
future brings and I'm not gonna waste my
time trying to assume what it's going to
be nor should you the way the Bible
describes the future it's like it's like
Vapor it's like Mist it's like a smoke
right it has a form and sometimes you
think that forms something and then we
try to grab it just it's nothing it's
futile so like there's there's no reason
for me to be sitting there and try to
piece the puzzle I work as hard as I can
I pray for opportunity and through this
like cycle of life I've found the sauce
of always being happy because I think a
lot of anxiety depression is if you're
if you're anxious you're thinking about
the future if you have depression you're
thinking about the past and if you're if
you're in the present it's a present for
from God it's a gift so I'm trying to
master this element of like being here
and knowing that regardless even if I
killed it or if I didn't kill it the
outcome is there's going to be a grave
one day for me and then throughout time
people are gonna forget what I did so
I'm not gonna sit here what you just
said I think is as true as it gets you
know what I mean so I just try to like
touch this
you have some man hands I feel bad that
my girlfriend called these big Palms bro
you would never make it as a gay porn
never do you make every dick look small
yeah did you just around with them see
what happens dude just just real quick
oh man yeah so I I take it day by day
and um
you know and it's gonna sound really
stupid and cheesy but like growing up my
dream was just one Dream create art that
the world knows who George Janko is in
his art form I got that and I realized
that my happiness is the same as the guy
who's flipping burgers at Five Guys and
it's because that guy was in the moment
hanging out friends being with family
and so like The Grass Is Always Greener
the people that have money are like man
I missed the days where I was at a nine
to five and I just didn't worry about
anything and the people that are nine to
five are like man [__] this out I can't
wait till I'm My Own Boss and I have to
do and I just realized that like I don't
want to be the dude that complains man
my friend
um they hit a marker he made a billion
dollars a little over a billion dollars
that I said yeah and I said uh that's a
billion dollars I was like yeah I can't
fathom that that's a lot of money I
couldn't fathom it and he was looking
the the the there was a moon and he
looks and he goes he goes
yeah I got friends that were worth 11
billion dollars it's not that big a deal
trust me
and I went
that's where comparison [__] that's
what happens to somebody you have to be
careful of that yeah
because but dude after after 300 million
like everything's the same but there's
in your life goes but it goes like this
it goes like like there are certain
actors that are crushing it they're mad
they're not Denzel
Denzel's mad he's not directing movies
you know it just keeps going man it
never ends I know very famous legends
I've had conversations with very famous
people famous people without naming
names and the one thing they were saying
is how they they just they they don't
get the respect that they you know
they're trying to get and this guy won't
give me the move it's biting their head
it's all in the respect it's on that it
it it if you're not careful no matter
where you are you're always going to be
you can find a fight always yeah if
you're looking for it like everybody
suffers from that so it's like you're
right about the guy flipping Burger but
you want to do what now just when you
say create content in what form I want
to get that and I know [__] Blazer
back out dude
you saw my new song as a bot bro you
have a new song yeah and you can't play
that because that is well I will take
the credits
can we play it and not put on the
episodes so we can hear it
because I had a dude you want to hear
the story real quick well before we play
this song I want you to know I've seen
all 23 season American Idols okay
go to a heart of David go to Heart of
David heart of David Andy Kramer no no
so yeah heart of David George Janka
there it is we're working is it
christian music
isn't it isn't I speak about my
relationship with God and just listen to
the lyrics it's a very storytelling type
uh and I'll tell you where it came from
this is all Freestyle by the way nothing
was written hit it
yeah
[Music]
and then it goes into this like Bridge
with the sample and then I go back into
freestyling that's so good that's good
God you've come a long way are you Kanye
West of Syria
bro I am oh I knew except for I like the
juice yes that's what I'm saying because
they're the chosen ones yes
that song was fire the guy who produced
this produces for Kid Cudi and everybody
and my friend Tanner Fox is a huge Kid
Cudi fan and he goes man I love you
kidding I go oh my friend produces for
him I can introduce you guys and as soon
as I said that I remembered I had a
dream that night like literally that
night I was like in my dream he produced
me a song that everybody liked and I was
like oh so as a joke I told him I go bro
I had a dream you produced me a song and
he goes dude I had a dream I produced
you a song and so I was like what the
[__] so we went to the studio and he
made this this like Kanye style to send
it to his team to maybe see if one day
in the future he could work with Kanye
West or whatever it was so I got on it
and I freestyled on it and then he's
like you know what it's yours bro yeah
that was dope yeah good for you thank
you and that's out right now yeah that's
out right now man we're working on a
music video you've been way fun if it
was horrible
you know if it was bad I know honey what
are we gonna do
it was really good in a mood I got I got
into a Groove thank you and I'm old
but I do this
the whole time Brown was on just when
you do that yes
it's just that's what you know you look
over running them and you just see that
you just see my jeans Darkness
no just a big boat just rock hard yeah
do you like it yeah no I just piss
he pisses [__]
yeah that was really really good I I
have some questions
if I could ask you yeah fire away man I
don't sing the whole thing let me fix it
well no this is actually about stand up
yep because when you ask me what do I
want to do I want to
um
it's so funny dude I I realize I just
want to create things I want I want
something here to come out there so I
could express myself without just being
a [__] [__] that's on a mic being
like this is how I feel and everybody
should validate it and like I just
realized that the the first version of
that was just art you know people
Express themselves and some people [__]
with it some people don't and um
when we left the podcast I got I had to
look up Joe Rogan stuff because I got
grilled in the comment sections for like
not knowing too much you know Joe did
stand up I didn't know too much about
Joe the only thing I knew about him is
that he just doesn't take [__] from
nobody that's literally the only thing I
ever knew and um monster Comic monster
[__] there's a lot of leaks out there
thirty years has been doing stand-up
yeah big dick but I the the one thing
that I I grew is like I need to be like
him I need to be like I'm okay getting
the money that I get or whatever I'm
getting for myself do me and if people
[__] with me they [__] with me and if
you cross that line with me I'll Grill
you and so I just want to build a
community within people that I love and
trust and have them prosper and then
through that we could build a little bit
more out out and out instead of working
out and having the whole world love me
for me to start in if that makes sense
yeah I feel I feel like you're North
Star don't get me wrong Joe Rogan's a
great North Star but for what like the
talent you have it's more of like a
Donald Glover
crazy compliment and you know I always
tell my girlfriend I go man I wish one
day somebody Compares me to him there
you go you just crossed off one of my
buckets yeah there you go thank you bro
as far as the north are like grogan's
very intense and don't get me wrong
monster Comic but like the acting stuff
like the singing different personality
yeah you just you're dead very different
great North Star as far as the way he
lives his life he's the best look for
one star like who you look up to like
you're like like your North Star like
you're on a boat and you gotta sail
towards that yeah yours is Charles
Gambino am I allowed to put my foot here
yeah 100 do everyone after that music
nice Chucks thank you they're not trucks
yeah but yeah
look at my face close up on my face but
uh yeah he's gonna try to be cool he
falls asleep yeah yeah my defense
mechanism is just to fall asleep he's
like those fainting goats he tries to be
cool sick kicks
[Music]
whenever you try to be cool no you just
know it but it has to be after you say
it's not shocks watch this try it again
those are cool chunks man thank you
they're not trucks
[Applause]
just always wrong yeah but it's got to
be a pause
huh yeah
but you look at you know Donald Glover
has he he did stand up yeah has a
special on Netflix really yeah I don't
know anything about it he didn't stand
up and you know he's always been super
talented
um music wise and then when he was on
that show Tina Fey was like because
you'd always created Atlanta didn't he
that's all I'm talking about right pass
out for me so when he uh when he got
Dynamic when he was in Tina Fey back in
the day on that show it was it what was
it uh Community Tina Fey he'd always
freestyle and stuff when they're uh not
shooting she's like you you're so
talented you've because he can sing too
she's like you've got to do something
with this and that's when you get
Childish Gambino
I love
when somebody's successful
and doesn't get intimidated from
somebody else who has talent and it's
like hey you should do that no you know
what I'm saying fire you yeah inspire
you shouldn't [__] make you but
that's also why broken me your no star
is also good because Rogan's the same
way if he sees Talent he's not like oh
God this competition don't get started
in this lane or this Lane he's like not
run with it dude yeah no I had to I had
to I had to
it's start navigating who I listen to
and who I don't listen to means
everything it means everything because
sometimes you you look up to somebody
and they definitely look down at you
well they want to suppress your dream
they don't want you to be in the same
Lane because they view this competition
and it's just it's such a it's a hard
it's a hard thing to understand right
because if you don't get that type of
personality
I if you don't do that to people you
dislike it's very hard for somebody to
understand why somebody you love would
do that it's famine thinking it's it's a
a really silly way to think how do you
think they mean to do it no the the pie
is only so bad sometimes they just don't
know they don't know you've got it then
I I can't get it you're taking what I
want so it becomes this the pie is only
so big and you're taking that's why you
you get a lot of hate in the the in
stand up right like other stand-ups like
well he's doing good he's selling
tickets and then they'll be they'll go
bad on that comic it's like no no them
having success has nothing to do with
you zero there's enough tickets out
there for everybody to sell yeah it's
written nothing really sad how that
how that works it never works out for
anything but also if you if you I truly
do believe you know they always say last
guys finish last nice guys finish last
yeah nice guys finish last night I don't
believe it I believe I believe it
there's a great book on this called give
and take that one Apple's book of the
year and it proves the exact opposite
nice guys when you so so there's the um
Adam Grant the youngest Professor
tenured professor at Wharton Business
School genius I interviewed him twice
this book called give and take I know he
uh he uh you could compromise how about
when he flexi results no I read I read I
interviewed him twice I'm friends with
him
and he uh that's how you lie ipaso yeah
but he does an amazing third job in the
book because he he does a case study
in politics and business and show
business name a nice guy in politics
politics Show Business and uh and um
a number of people who ended up being
what he because there are matchers
matchers I give you if you give me then
there are takers who are like they just
take and then there are people who give
and they give to people that are worth
it you don't give to an idiot you give
to people that are worth it and don't
expect anything back right because you
like the way you do and the way I do not
finishing last right now no no no no so
so that he did a really in I'm gonna
have you read this book Bob because he
he does this amazing and he's bleeding
is he bleeding get out of the frame come
on Chad I always stress her out what if
we thought he was a nice guy but his
sister comes he's like God damn it
whoa kicks her in the back from the
Stars you're always trying to steal my
shine boot Prince on her back on her
shirt we just continue with nice guys
finishing last well uh you should you
should read this book you should read
this book give and take because he does
a very
is an exhaustive study on the people
that gave and what happens is you're a
taker like a guy like Mike Ovitz who was
the biggest believe me the biggest I'm
not a taker no but but there's you know
there are people that are that scam you
that are just they're they're all about
the wrong coattails
okay if you look at what happens is if
you screw enough people over
what what people will invariable do this
is in politics this is in business
anywhere you get ahead for a while
you'll make some money but you [__]
enough people over and people start
talking and there becomes a network of
people that will conspire to [__] you
over now they will ostracize you they
will go I don't do business with you
don't do business with him and in
today's world where information is so
quick it's devastating now that includes
people that match if you become a
strategic Giver we're like I give you
know come back you get found out these
people get found out but over a long
period of time yes now givers givers
that this includes with I was surprised
by politics Show Business and business
people that do favors for people that
they believe in just because it's the
right thing to do pay it forward
those people end up always ahead because
what happens is enough people conspire
to help them it's almost like
subconscious it's like God energy enough
people get together bro and they will
start and they will push that person who
is it and it won Apple book of the year
because because he did such an amazing
job of showing this with case study
After Case Study after case study and
it's fascinating the reasoning he looked
at people who did this in politics and
he said and you would find that these
people had like they had lists of people
that they thought were worth it and they
would just help them and who were the
examples I can't remember the examples
but people you would know right away and
I was just it was just Dave Rubin I
think was one of them you know Dave
Rubin the the great producer music
producer oh yeah David the beard yeah
he's great people love that guy Rick
Rubin I'm sorry
Rick Rubin because Rick Rubin helps
people and he just helps people because
it's the right thing to do I think that
was one of the case studies but there
are a lot of things like that where you
go damn it makes sense and then he shows
you how many people were household names
that were killing it who were making all
the money and just got ostracized yeah
because you were a taker and you got
found out you were a matcher you got
found out now he makes a distinction
don't just be a giver to people that
aren't worth it don't just give to
morons don't give to people that are
that's my problem money after bad money
after bad I have some really good ones I
give to that have some horrible ones but
you might that's it that's a genius
yeah but you find a starving genius
that's who you give money to you
understand you give money to people that
have hustle that work hard and that just
want you know they just want the most
out of life those are the people that
you end up helping I I see it uh
almost identical but my source comes
from a different point
um how I grew up how my mom and dad
taught me in life is uh regardless of
what I did in this industry it has
nothing to do with me there is another
George Janko out there that's 10 times
more talented 10 times uh better looking
and has more of an IT Factor than me
always but
I truly believe because when God puts
something in my hand the first thing
that I think of is okay how can I
disperse this in my heart so if if
there's a father in Heaven I believe
he's going to bless the homes of the men
who are looking to actively bless his
other children too so okay not just
freeze them
mentality yes and freeze that for a
second whether God exists or not I
always say this to people when you
behave
he goes off
is that how you fall asleep
your body has to relax first dude you
gotta just not if it's Rick and mortis
yeah you literally he gets stiff it was
like you got electrocuted so that's like
the stiff goats that's what they do oh
that's true you watch too much goat
stuff
like no that's the north Belize goat
dude I've seen it that's so funny goats
do this though they faint like this
yeah you like this like when I got
knocked out by Ben Rothwell they're just
like yeah no no
no hold up
this walk as if there is okay
that again over and over is proven
there's another book called never read
alone about this Never Eat Alone by
Keith farazi a friend of mine really
good book about this all these authors
are your friends and their billionaires
welcome to the fire okay so so Tom
Cruise and I have a Time Sheriff I don't
have time
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's no camera no oh no no
I love him yeah oh that's I loved it
yeah but authentic but yeah so so that
that that idea is when you walk that way
when you walk at least when you try to
have Christ energy not Julius Caesar
energy you can say whatever you want but
you there is countless examples of you
are at least if not ahead a happier
person you're doing the right thing and
there's something that you get strength
from you become an example you become
somebody who's less you not you're kind
of Untouchable in that sense and that's
my argument and people respect that of
course they usually know a lot more if
you're going to come on air I'm not
saying you would or if we made this show
about drama or listen I could do
seven years of podcasts on drama you
could easily we were just actually
talking you guys gave me a lot of notes
behind the camera Guys these two did
look after me uh through situations and
and like you get you guys gave me that
big brother especially you you gave me
that big brother Vibe of like you know
hey don't do this do this and I just
wanted to say on camera and off camera
like I really appreciate you guys as
humans of course thank you yeah you're
good we like you bro we know we see good
when we when we I know good when I see
it I think all three of us kind of well
I don't know if you guys are on a
spiritual uh Journey but like my thing
is this bro like if you have a problem
with me which I pray you don't and if
you if you go behind closed doors and
and gather and gossip and you're trying
to Brandon will beat the [__] out of you
right not only with my boy Brandon come
after you yeah yeah but if me and God
have a relationship where he tells me
shut up sit down do nothing the next
commandment is gonna be he's gonna step
in and so I feel bad for my enemies
because I'm not coming after you I'm not
wasting time gathering information I'm
not going to go and and and block out
your name or or cast you or curse you or
anything you're too busy making content
I just don't know what it's not my
personality and bro the one thing that I
tell people that they always come up to
me like yo what's the one advice to be
in this industry I don't even give them
industry advice I give them this I go
the goal is you're not going to be able
to turn everyone's heart I go but the
goal is to make sure not everyone turns
your heart because I feel like every day
that's all I'm fighting dropping gems I
tell them that all the time all the time
I'll call him with something like dude
he's like don't change don't change
because my heart for a while was
starting to get pretty black it hurts
but I said stay tuned your loved ones do
it when you're like [__] me bro yeah
when friends do it you stay generous you
keep giving and you and but you tell the
truth always you tell the truth you you
align yourself with the truth we want to
be in your band I said it I said it out
I want to be in your guys's band we
think with our help we could all open
for Bieber
I you know he's definitely seen me talk
about this at least once and the fact
that he isn't DMS you know his favorite
comedians Chris D'Elia
he goes to Chris's shows
so you open for delete
okay don't laugh
you're not good at doctors too you're
not you can't do it that way it's got to
be just just let your just
all the energies out yeah that's all
Justin Bieber probably hasn't heard
about you
I wasn't ready too long okay ready and
action
George Justin Bieber probably hasn't
heard of you
[Music]
[__] that's Spotify
he got shot by a sniper and that's what
happened and he fell forward I think I
think a Mormon finally got him good the
problem
stay there he's got a tail piece on him
that's why we like you and it wasn't
even on camera
our cameras don't pick up the phone
camera
I knew [__] was bad when I saw him go
like this
oh you did you I eventually did I got
him a little bit on the ground though oh
thank God that sucks it would have
awesome to catch him so far I'll do it
I'll do I'll do it over here give me
another
hands are set that's good that was good
all right Jim what do you got buddy all
right
um so this is big news because
Andrew Tate has been in the news for a
long time who's Andrew Tate
he's a very oh he's the one that taught
me how to beat a girl how to beat a girl
yeah yeah he's out this is too soft you
got to come from the upper no that was
Dana White oh
oh I'll be here all weekend Atlanta
bunch line next Thursday Friday Saturday
wait wait hold on what's your honest uh
feedback on on an Andrew Tate because I
I don't I want to I want to get caught
up with you that are that that
commercial that uh tape where he was
beating that woman that was a consensual
thing I know that I know that she even
came on and said that she asked for it
he he I think at the end of the day is a
good guy an accomplished man who
probably says always if you really
listen to him be a high value male yeah
and then attract a high value female and
I think some of the things he says are
theatrical and strong but what I what
I've heard him say isn't that he's
saying anything bad I don't know enough
about the left is vilifying him because
he's completely he represents and has a
he's Unapologetic has a huge Army fall
in love yeah yeah but he's completely
against what the left wants you to
believe yeah he's he's there he now
right they need an enemy they need an
enemy that they got to focus on great
Trends on and [__] like that for a
reason they decide to pick on this
gentleman which is a terrible idea idea
and him being uh in jail in Romania is
awful dude awful bro awful as long as
time him and his brother spending there
is horrendous that's Rick he's an
American citizen it's horrible dude I
didn't know he's an American yes
um
my thoughts on this is this this makes
him bigger though before you go on what
they're doing 100 and his followers I
know people that love this man it makes
him way bigger they [__] up dude
you're [__] with the wrong guy it's
like when the left decides go after
people it's like God know who you're
[__] with I am like when they went
for Rogan he got bigger when they went
for they're going for Andrew trade it
makes them bigger that fan base this
feeds them yeah and I'm one of them and
what happens is they just keep pushing
me over so I uh I am not a friend of the
last what were you say I'm Godless left
I get it's so funny I get an argument
with my girlfriend and my sister all the
time I go I'm a huge fan of Andrew Tate
I'm a huge fan and if you are against
him it's probably because you're taking
his trolls too far correct and I think
he [__] up in that sense I think he
had a good like Mantra you gotta saying
like I'm with you he had a good uh uh
path but I think his pride got in the
way and he started leading a lot with
hatred instead of love I think the ante
kept going up up up up you know I like
for a long time there like even with
Logan Paul and those guys it's like they
make a video Trends right but you're
doing for a number of years and you're
trying to up the empty up the empty next
you know there's YouTubers like hey I'm
gonna jump off this building like Jesus
Christ how do we get here so even for
Andrew Tate like his message I'm on
board with most of it but the really
extreme ones I'm like and to me being in
the business like oh he's he feels this
pressure to up the ante up the ante the
problem is that when you do those
outlier kind of whatever takes that he
has the left and people don't like him
go see here he is this is him but he's
doing that's one of them they're doing
them they don't take it too far correct
like a lot of people like if you're left
you're an idiot like okay well hold on
it's where did we [__] where did we
get to where everything's it's divided
and and if you look at history every
single war starts with division so when
we're always bashing America for America
being stupid I don't ever understand
that my dad and mom left everything to
come to this country bro and I my dad
one time one [__] time in my it came
out of my mouth I go America's so
[__] stupid and he grabbed me in and
goes whoa
he goes you have no business talking
about this land you've never served for
it you never protected it and you never
did anything for it who the [__] are you
to talk about your country that's right
and I was like oh he goes in our country
we don't even have a land anymore but go
and try to talk about your their country
correct in a country that doesn't even
acknowledge them as their country
anymore he goes there's no more Pride
for where you're at and I think that we
need to get to a place where we're
telling our audience telling our younger
generation like it's not cool to [__] on
your country it's not let me let me let
me uh break it down the way Jordan
Peterson I thought was really
interesting and very easy that was that
why'd you go like that because as soon
as he starts the far left I have a
problem at the far left the people that
don't listen the people that are
idiologs I believe people that believe
in in mutilating children and things
like that real quick B you don't like
the far left you don't like the
extremist right correct correct yeah you
don't like either of those crazy no but
Jordan Peterson said you live you need
liberals you need people on the left you
need people on the right which I've
always said and I agree with because
liberals tend to be people that are are
arguing for what needs to change
and conservatives are arguing for what
needs to stay the same fair and those
are very important things because some
things in society need to stay the same
and Liberals are and left-wing people
are correct and some things need to
change but the far left want to take
down the foundation that's right and so
the reason you need open political
dialogue between left and right liberals
and conservatives is to figure out what
needs to be the best ideas and What
needs to stay the same yeah but it's
more manipulating now now
yeah social media has purified our Echo
Chambers and I'll tell you something
else
okay so okay first of all FYI is at
least been 15 years since I've been on
Yahoo
so I just want to lay it down Yahoo
either I just want to let you guys know
um I just immediately know your guys's
Age Now We're Here
chin yeah look at them I'm chin it's 14
years old dude you don't say
he's in a Syrian Korean he's a Syrian
Korean are you a Syrian
how do you think Jonas
a few facts he's Asian okay let that
factor into it
24. thank you appreciate it it's 45. I
know you're joking around by 24. oh no I
wasn't oh
you're 45. I thought I gave it away
gobble babies huh you gobble babies
yeah play the video I'm done looking at
you I know what you do with children
well there's some videos no videos so we
went to Yahoo for a picture so the whole
thing with Tate so he was released he
was like in prison him and his brother
Tristan were prison for for like nine
months and the girls that put them in
there came out like whoa we're of course
to say this he never did any of this
yeah well it's okay hold on nine months
I think I think it was nine months a
while I don't know if it was nine but
he's there no way I could have used it
for a while
like either way so anyways he finally
got released him and his brother got
released and they're two quote-unquote
accomplices the girls that were involved
with the whole
alleged sex trafficking kind of stuff
whatever
um anyways so this is I thought this was
funny when he got released he tweeted
this particular thing here on the top
absolute Clarity of mine real thoughts
real plans Vivid pain uh one hour home
and I can't stay on my phone some habits
die hard must defeat shaitan
is an evil demonic spirit in Islam that
tempts it's actually Satan and then his
brother Tristan tweeted this
the four months part oh his brother's a
little awful okay four months I'll put
on a pair of alligator shoes the
struggle is real his brother's funny I
love Ric Flair
um so these are the girls that are
apparently the complexes so by the way
he they were gone for four months oh
four months four months yeah hold on
those professionals are what no so these
are apparently the accomplices that
helped to get the girl whatever you know
it's it's alleged you know if you could
you elaborate what do you mean
accomplished to be a part of the whole
scheme of they're the skills to be like
sex trafficking yes whatever which by
the way is not even like a a fact like
grooming girls like that was what the
left put out like he's in sex
trafficking which isn't why they picked
him up but then also hey hey brothers
quit going to [__] Romania dude
because if you're here well they also
live here
stay here
and then I think well we can fly them
here though I think he should stay
that's what's in Romania maybe I think
he's doing good there is that the same
girl or is those two different girls
they look the same but they're
Georgina's on the left luana's on the
right figure it out good God they're
they're
uh they'll get on plane though
yeah but they're in room our audience
gonna see that they'll see the pictures
so I'll keep the comments to myself
um pretty one of them looks a little
Manish Manish
okay so you guys all know and I'm gay
all right am I
am I oh [__] he passed out
anytime I have a gay thought I pass out
he has fanting goat disease
passed out you made out with him oh man
this little dude's in some [__] let me
say this I and I'm not looking wait he's
under Fire yes
dude he beat the [__] out of this cat
he did he's on record being this cat
here's my attention I tell me if I'm off
in the MMA Community he did dude in that
memory Community he's big right like
anything post gets like a million
[__] retweets maybe I'm older I don't
understand I don't obsession with him I
do not get it I know he's you know he's
from Dagestan
I'll show you the video and don't laugh
no no I'm saying like when you see it
you'll see it and just judge for
yourself okay here's the video here's
basically
what the [__] he's pulling the ear of
the cat look
the cat the cat goes into it he said the
cat disobeyed him yep
oh that's nice so he does this
wait why would he post that bro I don't
know I think I don't think he posted
that no he did he was in a story so he
did this this and then people went Adam
about like and he took it down no no I
don't know he did it what was he doing
was he he said he said she disobeyed I
schooled it but obviously the audio
listeners won't know what's going on
because it's in so you're looking at us
I'm so sorry but like I've seen some
apology videos
[Music]
long story short he says I wasn't
abusing the cat I didn't really hit him
that hard I pulled his ear I was
scolding him for misbehaving I love cats
more than I love you that's cool
basically us
I don't think he'd be canceled I love
cats smarter than you
he's on somebody yeah I don't uh yeah I
don't think he's gonna cancel what are
you gonna cancel them from right I guess
here's a deal with the UFC I know that I
also think I also think that that was uh
I also feel like the cat yeah would you
say I I don't think I wouldn't label
that as beat in the cat but also don't
hit animals but also I'm gonna be honest
with you I disagree I think if your
cat's going like this when you're
walking up to it that means you've you I
agree my cat doesn't go like this when I
come up 10 bro yeah you know my camera
you ever go to pet somebody's dog y'all
hey man what the [__] is going on at
this house yeah yeah no I don't I don't
I don't con I by the way like you don't
even if you are uh you know teaching him
a lesson which by the way Studies have
shown that's not how it works with cats
yes is it possible to say this that he
in his mind
loves his cat and was disciplining it
without thinking he was hurting it is
that possible no because some people
think they could do that with their
wives and their kids especially in
Dagestan especially there especially
where he's from
um I don't know about that Pakistani
guarantee has a lot less domestic
violence than say the United States you
think women have more rights than
daggers down there no but I think the
United States violence is way worse we
have more people we have way more people
we have more people yeah but there are
philosophies when it comes to women
though don't put your hand up like that
yes type of comment right drugs and
alcohol super comfortable alcohol drugs
and alcohol
that was good uh no I I just I don't
know I don't think this you know I think
anything you put out there is gonna feed
into it right everything's a mustard
seed so if somebody that does look up to
him or like likes his content is like
falling down to him
nobody's here
how do you guys still have careers I
don't know dude
they're coming back
uh can you imagine if Dana was okay
after seeing that video where we have we
no longer have association with uh this
dude for hitting that cat
actually I signed Maura Dana's video
that I see this one because the cat cat
you know what I'm saying like she hit
him first that's what I'm saying like
the cat was never like there man yeah
the cat was not listening before he's
just being a [__]
that cat looks like the cat the actual
cat from Puss and Boots Bro Look at nah
bro that's [__] that stop come on
dude that's not it wasn't too hard right
bro he's also he's running away here
it's fish sad bro it's not good to do
that either I would say it was a stupid
thing to do
it just lay your body relax okay [__]
just just watch watch just just
that's all do you have to do your eyes
like that [__] man
all right so this is kind of shocking to
me uh
I'll just play this I don't know how
this popped up in my feed but it just
did so this is that from Crazy Town yes
so I'll just play this real quick come
visit him now at a guitar store
[Music]
realize he looked like this who is this
uh his name is Shifty shell shock uh
Seth binser way he's before your time
when I was in high school this song was
mad wait that's the artist from the song
yes what happened uh math problem so he
had a lot of drugs he was on the
celebrity drug rehab thing show he
didn't do well on there is he clean he's
clean now oh good for him yes exactly
yeah he looks like he's doing well
so he's 48 years old Brian he's 48 but
the way that the drugs hit him it's just
like it sucks dude they catch up with
you man I mean I I look only a little
bit older no you don't look older at all
you look way younger brother
no I think what's true I think you and
him both look good
I love being in that horse I like doing
this bit I love this podcast
the best we're Pioneers 10 years have
been gone longer longer a little respect
hey so until he gets paid in catalytic
converter
it's so messed up
my girlfriend just got her stolen yeah
because I've never heard the toothless
version before um people are so mean but
so far but also you don't have any drugs
Converse
you'd be scared shitless if he started
performing on like Third Street like you
grab your kids it's just cool because we
remember he was like a good looking dude
like you know in shape and he's being
the hottest girl show Brian right he's
never seen it
come come my lady you're my sugar pie
all right
that's him he was
oh what a bummer that was him that's the
music video for this song I think yeah
that's it whoa yeah I just remember
those start that man that guy has a
story huh oh huge story uh all the
stories yeah wow he's ripped yeah he's a
good shape and everything yeah I think
you can get back
he dated soil Moon fry Punky Brewster
okay use it back I think some porn stars
and stuff as well but yeah he kind of
looks like Joe Rogan right there which
one how dare you except for that
experience wasn't great like right there
the bottom left oh I see who is that who
is Seth I'll tell you who that is
yeah man Joe Rogan yeah that's tough
It's a trip man
yeah wow um really awful by the way to
see him at least he's sober though yeah
yeah see him now that's like a parallel
music video game you're like The Walking
Dead put him in a music video he can be
in our band but he's gonna dance in a
cage
dude you guys are wild see you guys
too far you guys are wild bro like yo
I've been on some podcasts and we're
like uh and we'll get like like ballsy
and then after like can we scrub that
part and then you guys are say some [__]
where I'm like scrub free scrub free no
YouTube YouTube is like this right now
when are they gonna learn
by the way I love how people type in
your mind when are they gonna learn
all right shout out to our boy jelly
roll jelly won three uh Country Music
Awards last night he won the most Awards
he won the most and performed oh my God
who's uh who's post Malone here I don't
know this is jelly that's thick Malone
dude that jelly was he was a country he
was a rapper first went to prison got
out of prison day gets up talked about
fate gets out of prison his boy back in
there in the Razer flip phones films him
because he would freestyle in prison as
he gets in his house and you're selling
drugs and they go dude freestyling is
not the freestyle he does a freestyle
they upload it it goes crazy viral so he
becomes a pretty big rapper then that's
when I meet him right that's why I've
known probably eight years now and then
he gets big into country music now he's
the number one country music singer in
the world number one I'm sorry
what he dominated CMT 2023 Awards you
would love him first of all I don't know
just his smile he shows me that he's
he's like a good dude he's a real one
the best wow also post Malone was a good
dude I heard all right yeah post
Malone's dope jelly rolls won the salt
of the earth so he writes his music and
just everything everything so we do uh
thick Boy albums like thick boys
not in jail to that nuts nuts he's so
talented what was he in jail for drugs
drugs sweet man uh selling or taking
selling what a good guy man that's it
but also you didn't get tattoos on your
face you're not trying some right
bro did he have that before the music
industry yeah yeah yeah I've never known
bro that is that is a blessing
whoever recorded him he had to have
gotten something right
I doubt it right I don't know
something what do you mean
I don't know what else you got Jen uh
how many more do you want real quick
just just give us the KSI one because I
don't know what's going on with KSI KSI
I saw a massive case I was either I
don't know how big of a deal he was oh
like as a human just as like on YouTube
and like just following I had no idea
nice guy too he's a good guy I've heard
that oh very nice guy yeah
I actually have a I recorded him
listening to my song he made it what's
the racial story he's black uh so we
can't really say the racial slur but
apparently it's it's an a instead of an
yeah instead of that star it's an A so
I'll just play this clip it's gonna be
uh censored anyway and that's a racial
slur I didn't know that until today
I don't mean this maliciously what the
what
what is it what do you say
and South Asians yeah no they it's it's
it's a so in it used to be in in England
well if you're Pakistani having lived in
Pakistan having family friends who are
Pakistan uh in in when I grew up
overseas if you wanted to be derogatory
to somebody who was Pakistani especially
in England you would call them pakis and
in fact uh Amir Khan and his brother I
believe were on the street and a couple
of skinheads in Britain called him and
his brother pakis he beat him up and
they knocked and americana's brother
beat the [__] out of those guys like
knock them out I didn't know if so
so it's not I thought it was a short
condensed but in England that would be
when you came as an immigrant from
Pakistan you you were you were called to
pack hey B now I'm not saying I'm not
saying this I'm saying is it like this
is it like you know when we're at war
with Japanese over here we call them
Japs is that the same thing probably
it's just that right pakistanis Pakistan
that's offensive I would say oh yeah
that's the reason
it comes from the Pakistani Community
probably in the Indian Community because
with Pakistan when the pakistanis would
came to the UK like all immigrants they
took menial jobs they took whatever they
could work for they're a very
conservative culture they're Muslim
they're very conservative they're very
tight family units
um and and like a lot of cultures like
that they work their ass off and they
ended up developing some political power
uh they're all very educated a lot of
money and then like anything else you
develop Pride you get sick of being
called a Packy you develop a political
movement you you get loud online and now
when you hear somebody say that you go
hey [__] you call my father had
to deal with that [__] yeah when he was
working my mother had to deal with that
I'm sure KSI and especially in England
yeah it's even yeah and that's a big
thing in England because I would also
remind people that in England when you
were called a [__] but you got beat up
and it's not good so like the way you
did in school you know a lot a lot of
kids would go home they'd get the [__]
beat out of them and so you you can
understand that it's just you can also
understand how you made the mistake too
he's like I [__] up my bad I didn't
we're learning yeah he's young he's
going into it knowing that it's a bad I
agree he was like uh yeah
Family Guy or like that one episode of
South Park remember when they're like
trying to fill in the yeah and he says
the N word yeah yeah I feel like I felt
like I knew it was gonna recreate that
yeah he knew it was gonna be bad because
he goes I shouldn't use this word but it
came up and he says the word yes yeah
yes I don't think you realize the
blowback what was the word
so how could he get in trouble if the
word was that I don't know the game so
remember Pakistan no no no I know that
I'm saying we know it's bad in the game
you mean in the game
but let me just give you this little
historical context not to be boring to
everybody but if you were Pakistani
Pakistan was a country that was formed
and founded in 1947. the partition of
India happened in 47. so what that was
was the Muslim Community in India
actually walked to what is now modern
day Pakistan and created the state of
Pakistan okay and they were Muslim and
you're [__] dude but the point is
that it was a British colony wasn't it
so when a Brit calls you a [__] they
were called that when they were
colonized so now that term yeah now
people get people like hey [__]
it's a different it's a new day how does
it feel holding all that information I'm
just old and I lived overseas my whole
life and I have lots of Pakistani
friends yeah
I lived there for two years of my life
and my parents lived there in Karachi
and Islamabad of total of four years
who knows the latest come on man is that
itching uh can we do what are Georgie's
yeah please all right
here's one
this is uh remember I'm delivered I
don't like men's anymore
oh this is beautiful so I'll just play
real quick I'm not gay no more I am
delivered
[Music]
I'm not gay no more so someone played
the success metal type music
women
[Music]
I'm not gay no more well so that's a
very viral clip as you guys know oh yeah
no more was that a real church event yes
yes or was that a skit No the real event
you've never seen the real it's one of
the most watched videos of all time oh
that guy makes my heart that guy
actually got sued by Cordell Stewart
because he said he had a relationship
with Cordell when Cordell was in the NFL
yeah oh what's this it's the last one
it's boys yeah yeah I I love this guy
actually
so he's running from home
oh you got a little lost wait wait
he's Tony slides he's safe he didn't
mean to oh that's great my guess is he
probably has some he has some I'll Cry
he's big that's all yeah is that that's
it it seems like I don't know I don't
know the details on this yeah good good
yeah don't give him [__] don't oh I have
some mental retardation I didn't say
that no dude
I like that he I like that he's out
there playing the game well he said he
clearly has some mental issues that's
fine
that's fine no I don't think he does
don't do that to him I'm not saying he
does I want I think I know who the guy
who beat the gay out of the person
pull that I think I uh call back baby
kids though you just you just you want
to hug that kid that's all I can say
yeah I don't think any issues but I see
a kid like that and I just want to hug
him
I feel bad for him
it's a good video he slides and Brian's
like this poor mental [__] I did not
say that oh geez if you want to hit it
with this we can do we can't play the
actual real footage but
that's the yes that's why it's so funny
because they picked a girl so this is
for a breast exam live on TV and they
actually showed the real nude breasts
why should they pick the girl that has
Double J something like that those are
impossible teams
I call those impossible tits if you
don't mind taking and releasing them
sweater hitters for us
they're just gigantic
no way her nipples this isn't America is
it no no no this is like in England or
something like that this is on
television live television I think they
can do that there for watching and KSI
that's a big lady we picked the biggest
[Music]
how do you guys still have a career bro
how did they find is there a picture of
her sliding into home
bringing bring it back bro no this is
not okay bro like I mean what she's
doing is fine but like I'm going to
examine her 38. did you do that in the
privacy of your like 30 Acres Double J
puppies dude yeah who said that she did
she posted this me with these 38 Double
J I'm fine with it as long as they
should televise something that's coming
out checking to make sure he has no
cancer on his balls
good luck
up now I know
yeah I had a rough childhood how about
it did they find anything else these
giant tits as far as I didn't find
anything then
that'd be 14 years old their breasts and
she had a breast examination
guts to be live on TV in London in the
United Kingdom God bless her and she
didn't take her piercings out and I
think that's why where did they find
this model
we're all 14 years old I'm not I'm
saying I I appreciate they gave her a
live breast exam on live TV because
you're both canceled but why though why
do you why do you why why is that like
because I'm trying to be politically
correct politically correct put your
shirt on and go to the doctor what the
[__] you doing this in front of
everybody but or or hey we just tested a
backstage turns out blah blah blah we
don't need to see that bro like and by
the way it's not like there's nothing
wrong there's nothing wrong with it but
it's just here's my how much [__] have
you guys like said no to but then that's
okay here's my problem like I'm trying
to eat my scrambled eggs I got Double J
tits in my face it's a it's all very
strange and I'm gonna say something
that's gonna sound like if you're really
worried about breast cancer I think we'd
be better off you teach somebody how to
do a breast exam it's all good but I
think breast cancer can also be
correlated with a healthy lifestyle so
it just did so massive yeah what else
being a massive gorgeous careers
it's just the piercings that get me bro
it's the whole it's the whole thing
that's what makes me laugh it's just
like you you just you you wanted to they
did this so they could get attention
they got it I wonder if they really if
she knew what the [__] she got into she
was probably no no we get her tiny
little hand just mop up yeah but that's
how they do it yeah they say go from the
outside first they're feeling for lumps
yeah
it's educational I do that I'm rock hard
but yeah
it's so awkward though I don't know why
it's awkward it's just awkward but yeah
she just stand there like you see her
bite her lips
they could have done it with a mannequin
too but I guess it's fine I don't think
it's a big deal a man can take his shirt
off why can't a woman you know what I'm
saying guys
how long until you're on crowd and
Crowder here's this give me a [__]
give me a breast exam
guys get breast cancer
not with your little flat chest though
you don't have oh let me look nope no
lumps
why'd you get quiet bro
you run out of steam you're living in
the same thing no no I'm just in my mind
I'm like registering I'm like I could
can I get in trouble for this and if I
do get in trouble for this do I really
want my car to go out from Double J
breasts on a bridge all we're doing is
making just put this comment on what
happened with the heat on that's usually
how it goes if you want to be on the
varsity team this is how it goes all
right
[__] it yeah there you go big tits all
right you're right George lost steam
let's George we love you buddy go check
out George's pod thank you what's the
pod's name again uh the George Janko
show George Janko uh Atlanta Atlanta
next week uh Thursday Friday Saturday
only Atlanta Georgia La Jolla Comedy
Store June 2nd through the 4th then I'm
off to Europe Belfast Glasgow Manchester
London Cardiff Dublin is all this uh my
tour dates
for a new listener I would have never
known you just started naming oh but
yeah we've been doing so long right
there I know but I I would like to do
this all right I got you I'll be in
Portland Oregon uh April 20 21 22. come
get some and then come give a calendar
Charlotte Florida Comedy Zone visani
theater May four five and six
uh fight campaign is Saturday 7 P.M live
Pacific UFC 287 you're on it you me
Cheeto Vera and a very special guest yep
Cheetos Cummins please don't ask stupid
questions but you can't give them a
breast exam
um all right kids George we love you
thank you for having me what's going on
man
that was so much fun